thanks to dashlane for keeping legal
eagle in the air if this person goes
through and destroys that evidence
that's called spoliation of evidence ie
the destruction of evidence and as you
can guess that is in fact illegal so the
goal of legal eagle is to help explain
the laws that surround us I try my best
to accurately explain legal issues while
trying to keep things fun as well
but there are places on the internet
where you'll find let's say dubious
legal advice and one of those places is
the legal advice subreddit of Reddit
calm you may know reddit as the place
where you can post just about anything
it's the place where people are more
preoccupied whether they can post
something instead of whether they should
do i lurk on reddit I can neither
confirm nor deny that claim do i
sometimes post as anonymous lawyer 6 9 6
9 i won't comment on that but let's dig
into one of my favorite insane posts
from the last month a little background
about myself I've been a practicing
trial lawyer and veteran litigator for
over 11 years I spent 10 years as a
senior associate to the most prestigious
fault 100 firms in the country I've
represented hundreds of clients from
billion-dollar companies to individual
artists I passed the bar in five states
including California New York Maryland
Virginia and DC and yes I am considering
DC estate it is only a matter of time I
think this might be a continuing video
series on this channel so if you like it
please give it a thumbs up and send me
other examples of really terrible legal
advice at my Twitter handle at legal
eagle DJ because I'm DJ and you know
this is legal eagle all right so let's
dig in to the legal advice post I was
just directed by my boss to delete
metadata of files being submitted
because of a subpoena user para illegal
IT which is a great username posts
I was just directed by my boss to delete
the metadata files being submitted
because of a subpoena this is like
massively illegal right good guess we
are an insurance company and these files
contain plenty of private customer data
also contains payment history and down
payment information they want me to
delete the metadata which while totally
possible is something I told my boss was
impossible he called me on my BS and
told me to do it or get fired I am the
only IT guy so if I do not do it it will
not get done I'm thinking about walking
out the door right now and never coming
back I am also thinking of doing a full
win 10 reset on my personal PC what laws
if any would this violate who do I
report this to if illegal I will be
reporting it I hate this company I hate
my boss and I hate my coworkers
I would lose no sleep at them being
utterly destroyed by a judge somewhere
this is a company of five people so no
HR or legal department what to do now
before I dig into this I need to
obviously tell you that this is not
legal advice I am NOT your lawyer I'm
not offering legal advice neither to you
the viewer or to this particular user
para illegal IT I am just your friendly
neighborhood legal eagle your friend who
says everything that you do is always
illegal sorry to be the buzzkill but
stop doing illegal things so there's a
couple of things going on here it looks
like the boss here is trying to
accomplish one of several things number
one could be trying to make it harder
for the other side to review the
documents by deleting metadata or number
two he may be hiding evidence of
wrongdoing so not only will it make it
harder to review documents but he may be
getting rid of crucial evidence it
depends on the nature of the suit which
we don't happen to know here but let's
talk about how discovery works and how
this person found themselves in this
situation in civil discovery one side
sends document requests those are
allowed under the Federal Rules of Civil
Procedure rule 34 these requests have to
specify exactly what you're looking for
I mean right down to every single word
that is used in the request because if
there's any ambiguity it's going to
cause problems later on the other side
can object and if they continue to
object and refuse to comply then you
might have to go into court and get an
order forcing the other side to comply
with your document requests which is yet
another reason why the request should be
worded correctly because if you didn't
word them correctly then the other side
might not have to comply now that's just
between two parties to a lawsuit like a
plaintiff and a defendant but if you're
trying to get documents from a third
party then you have to issue what's
called a subpoena now a subpoena is
basically the same thing as a rule 34
document request it's just that there
are a couple
extra strings attached because you're
trying to get documents from someone who
has nothing to do with a lawsuit
whatsoever so give me a little bit more
difficult but generally you can get the
court to force them to comply as well
now as I said it's really important for
the document requests to be very very
specific because the lawyers on the
other side are going to scrutinize your
requests and if there is any way to get
out of that document request they will
find it so often you will have specific
language in your request that includes
electronically stored information like
metadata or you'll just have an
agreement with the other side to deal
with ESI back in the day document
requests just meant requesting actual
physical documents but now it's almost
always electronic documents things like
emails and databases and as a result the
federal courts and lots of different
states have created rules for dealing
with electronically stored information
like metadata in case you aren't
familiar with metadata it's described as
the data about data if you think about
an email that you receive that email
will have a subject line it'll have to
from BCC it'll have the body of the
email and the text of that email is
searchable all of that would be
considered electronically stored
information and much of that would be
considered metadata now imagine if you
took a picture of your email and then
you sent that picture to someone else
well you wouldn't be able to sort that
email by the to line or the from line or
the subject line and the computer can't
search the text of that picture because
it's just one block of information so
the metadata can be incredibly important
it can tell you when things were sent
when things were received it can tell
you what's inside of the document itself
so it can be not only important for a
particular lawsuit but it can also make
a lawsuit so much less expensive in
terms of searching things because if you
have just a bunch of emails then you can
sort them you can search them you can do
all of that stuff very easily you'll see
on TV often that the other side will try
to bury the other side in documents and
they'll just send a truck load over a
physical paperwork and sometimes that
does happen courts are savvy to that now
and if you try and pull that crap you
just go into court and you say look it's
ridiculous that they're trying to give
us paper documents when
it would've been easier for them to turn
over just a hard drive full of
information and we're not gonna go
through the expense of scanning all of
this information and then searching it
so what you see on TV has a grain of
truth but if you're a good litigator you
should be able to avoid circumstances
like that now in the circumstances that
are set out by para illegal IT it's
unclear how much data has been
subpoenaed but if the employer feels
that it would be overly burdensome to
have to respond to it the correct method
of dealing with that is not to delete
the documents and the information the
correct way of dealing with that is
called a motion to quash which is
basically just a motion you go into the
court and you say it's ridiculous that
we have to comply with us we're not
parties to this proceeding so why should
we have to undergo the cost of
responding to these ridiculous document
requests but the way I read this post is
that it sounds like the documents have
been identified and they are responsive
to the subpoena and it's not overly
burdensome to respond to them so that
means that if this person goes through
and destroys that evidence that's called
spoliation of evidence ie the
destruction of evidence and as you can
guess that is in fact illegal if the
court finds out that this company has
destroyed evidence they're probably
three different kinds of sanctions that
it would issue against the company and
potentially this individual first our
issue slash inference sanctions second
our monetary sanctions and third is
litigation ending sanctions destroying
the metadata could easily lead to
sanctions by the trial court based on
the assumption that the employer had
something to hide and as the employer
has effectively hidden whatever that was
the court would be forced to assume that
whatever the other party alleged was
true this could lead to what's called an
issue sanction meaning that a jury or
the court in this particular instance
would be instructed that whatever was at
issue had been determined in favor of
the other side effectively this would be
like a court required admission by the
other side this would of course negate
any advantage that the employer thought
he might gain by destroying the data
when you engage in these kind of
shenanigans what tends to happen is the
court orders you to pay the costs and
fees of the other side for having to
file a motion for sanctions or to try
and wreak
the data that you destroyed those are
called monetary sanctions and if your
conduct is bad enough then you can get
what are called litigation ending
sanctions where the court says you have
engaged in such a nefarious act that
we're going to end this suit and find
against you criminal sanctions are
possible but they're pretty unlikely
we've seen spoliation of evidence in a
few high-profile cases like the way Moe
versus uber litigation where they dealt
with a trade secret dispute over an
employee that left from one employer to
the other and in that case the plaintiff
sort of staked to the outcome of the
case on ubers destruction of text
messages saying that because Ober
destroyed these relevant text messages
that the court had to make a negative
inference against uber and therefore
basically the other side should have won
the case now generally you can only get
sanctions against the other side when
they have engaged in willful destruction
or sometimes grossly negligent
destruction of evidence that's why an
attorney will send what's called a
litigation hold letter to inform the
other side that they have to preserve
documents lest they be liable for
spoliation of evidence so what is this
hapless IT professional to do under
these circumstances well to figure that
out let's do our very first comment
review so the first comment of note
comes from Schiphol 61 which says first
are you being asked to permanently
delete the metadata or just remove it
from copies that will be produced in
response to the subpoena this is an
excellent observation we'll get to that
in just a second permanently deleting
metadata is likely spoliation of
evidence and is a huge no-no absolutely
correct however if you are simply
removing the metadata from the files
before production it could be okay
depending on the format in which the
files have been subpoenaed so what this
person is pointing out is going back to
what I stated at the very beginning of
this video which is that you have to be
incredibly precise in terms of what you
are asking for and often you'll have a
separate agreement about what to do with
ESI like metadata what this person is
pointing out is that perhaps this IT
professional has misunderstood what the
boss is asking and what's very common in
litigation is that
if you have agreed to turn over
electronic documents without metadata
then you would strip it out before you
turn it over to the other side and
assuming that there is some agreement to
that effect
that's totally okay that's absolutely
kosher
however in almost any circumstances that
I can think of if you have been
instructed to permanently delete the
metadata off of your computer or the
company's computer such that it can
never be recovered
that's definitely spoliation of evidence
so getting that kind of clarification
before completely freaking out would
probably be a good idea now user
natural-born citizen rights I would
definitely get this in writing ie just
to confirm are you requesting that I am
to delete all metadata from these
subpoenaed files or just certain fields
and if only certain fields which ones
then print and save the response
somewhere and if possible find somebody
at the applicable court to send a copy
to now I'm a little worried about
sending it to the court but it is almost
always a good idea to get things in
writing not only is it a good idea to
get it in writing from the particular
boss to make absolutely crystal clear
that he is asking this person to delete
permanently the metadata but he might
even copy the corporate counsel and make
sure that the council is aware of
potentially illegal spoliation of
evidence this might do a couple of
things number one the thing about
lawyers is that we tend to not like
illegal things going on under our noses
so if it's brought to the lawyer's
attention and it is what this person
says it is number one he'll get
clarification of what he's being asked
to do and number two he may have someone
champion his cause and intervene to try
and prevent the illegal destruction of
evidence and there's probably also a
third reason why it would be very very
important for this person to get this
instruction in writing most states have
laws that protect employees who refuse
to do illegal things and then are fired
by their employer and the only thing
better than doing the right thing is
having a paper trail of doing the right
thing now if I've learned anything from
reddit is that this redditor is just one
step away from changing all the
company's passwords and posting it to
our slash Pro revenge this companies
documents and data might not be safe
from a boss who wants his employees to
destroy evidence but you can help secure
your own data
passwords with - lane - Lane gives you
an all-in-one tool to protect yourself
online see - Lane syncs all of your
passwords and payment details between
all of your devices without ever knowing
those passwords - Lane protects your
identity across the internet by
providing a tool that generate strong
passwords stores and auto fills them
securely everywhere on the internet
completely seamlessly even across
laptops and phones running different
operating systems when you sign up for -
Lane you choose a master password that's
never transmitted over the internet not
even - Lane servers have your password
you enter your password once on each
device and then you never have to think
about it again
and for extra security - Lane premium
also includes dark web monitoring and a
VPN which acts as an intermediary to
make sure that all of your internet
traffic is encrypted even when you're on
public Wi-Fi - Lane does all of this in
one product for one small price instead
of requiring you to buy multiple
solutions with - Lane premium you're
getting a password manager VPN and dark
web monitoring for less than what just
one of those services usually cost try -
Lane free for 30 days at the link below
and if you like it you can get 10% off
of - Lane premium by using the promo
code legal eagle at checkout clicking on
the link here using the promo code
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis leave your
objections in the comments and check out
my other real lawyer reactions over here
where I will see you in court